foreign
the thought that popped into my head and
I was hoping we'd have an opportunity to
talk about it but it echoes exactly what
you're saying here is
and this is hard to say but I think it's
true
you will never get what you want
and let me expand on that a little bit
because
we often think we want something but
it's not what
we want it's what someone else wants for
us now advertisers are it's easy to make
them the boogeyman which we often do you
know we think advertisements suck we
don't like advertisements and and yet so
the desires that we have become these
mometic desires I saw it in a magazine
or I saw an influencer wearing it or I
saw it on YouTube or I just saw someone
walking down the street and they looked
good in that shirt or with that purse or
whatever it was and now I want it the
thing that I didn't even realize
was available to me I feel like I
couldn't live without it now
I want it so much
okay that's one kind of one
and we all know intellectually like
getting that isn't going to complete me
or whatever but there are some deeper
things that you truly want
and you'll get them sometimes
but when I say you won't get what you
want because what the thing you want is
never actually the thing you want
the thing you want is the feeling is
behind the thing right the promotion the
consumer purchase the relationship you
want the feeling behind that even some
virtuous Pursuits
I really want to contribute to my
community I want to build wells in
Africa I want to build orphanages right
great
but the thing you want is actually
behind the thing that you want
and the problem with getting what you
want is
we try to hold on to that thing
and if you hold on to the thing
that you wanted you got it but as you
hold on to it you cling to it what
happens you cease to want it in fact it
becomes a burden
I had the weirdest dream last night
I was uh walking around with this giant
it wasn't like a boulder but it was a
very big rock about the size of one of
these balloons up here it was a heavy
Rock
and in the dream Ryan was there was my
shirt on
it was a that was a different dream
a fantasy one might say
you have to be sleep for a Dream
we are bifurcating
[Music]
carrying this giant I was walking
carrying this giant rock around and Ryan
just shows up on the street and I'm
carrying it and he's like hey man that
looks heavy
this is just last night I said yeah it
is
he goes why'd you pick it up I said I
needed to pick it up he goes okay
because you know you can set it down
and it was just this Revelation like
I can set this down
but that isn't that true with the
expectations you were talking about yeah
well because the whole time you're
reading that I was thinking about all
the expectations I've had in my life and
the different attachments and the
desires and things that I've chased and
so many of them like I hadn't I didn't
even realize I picked them up
and it's easy to say and easy to
understand if you want to be truly happy
which
happiness is even we could talk about
that for an hour but for the for the the
sake of the the context here like to be
happy you have to let go of all your
desires let go of all your attachments
easy to say easy to understand but
man we pick them up so so many times
without even realizing that we're doing
it and it's not until we start to feel
that discontent that
whatever negative emotion it's creating
that then we have the opportunity to
kind of Let It Go rather than try to
it's I think it's harder to try and not
pick up any because it's just they just
happen naturally and that was the thing
in the dream
yes I knew I was carrying it but didn't
really realize that I picked it up and
it was just a part of my everyday
walking at that point and yes I knew I
had it but I didn't know what it was
doing to me but as soon as you see
that attachment that expectation for
what it is that's the only time you can
actually let it go I remember our last
Sunday Symposium there was a woman in
the back she asked a question
about how do I let go of something I
don't remember what it was and my answer
was hey the microphone you're holding if
that was a snake would you be asking me
how to Let It Go
and she said well no I said well what
would you do because she wouldn't come
to anyone and say
I need help letting this go I need a
three-step plan a method of Technology
whatever no because as soon as you see
the problem
that's when you have the ability to
actually drop it and that's why I wanted
to read that that intro today
uh Robert Fritz and a very excellent
book called The Path of least resistance
he talks about this idea of how we
typically rely on a process to give us
the faith to move our lives towards a
result and so we say unless I have a way
to lose weight I'm not going to lose
weight and so we wait on someone to
provide us with a process and then we
make the decision to lose weight and he
says it is the decision about the what
that gives rise to the how it's not
until you decide I'm going to be healthy
I'm going to quit smoking I'm going to
increase my income whatever it may be
that you actually get a process that can
take you there but if you seek
permission from processes what will
happen is you'll always find something
missing in the process because there is
no process that's created for you right
processes have to be created by you as a
result of committing to some end result
did you enjoy this Standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast available exclusively on patreon
visit patreon.com the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and YouTube
Channel 100
advertisement free